mais le goff bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors pour
commencer un point peut-être sur la
situation sur le site de caudan il est
toujours bloqué à 7 heures de talent est
toujours bloquée depuis mardi matin 10
heures le site est bloqué alors
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous demandez
concrètement on a rencontré le préfet de
région hier matin maintenant dans un
médiateur au niveau de la préfecture
pour pouvoir entamer enfin de vraies
discussions parce que ça va faire
maintenant on se fait mener en bateau on
n'y a pas de réponses à nos questions on
n'a pas de réponse sur l'avenir et suit
la conférence qui s'est passé lundi avec
monsieur le maire et les constructeurs
automobiles on n'est pas du tout en
confiance sur la pérennité du site et
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas en confiance
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire que
finalement la situation sent mauvais
pour vous tout simplement parce que la
semaine dernière on en compterait le
délégué ministériel interministérielle à
bercy qui nous confirment qu' il n'y a
pas de repreneur pour moment pour fonder
de bretagne et on est toujours sous le
couperet de la décision renault qui veut
se séparer de nous parce qu'il y avait
eu 1 c'est bien cela une promesse de la
part de renault il ya quelques mois
ouais ses promesses en fait c'est comme
d'habitude
renault tient pas ses engagements que ce
soit sur ce qu'elle avait dit au mois de
mai l'année dernière que ce soit sur les
volumes
donc c'est pour ça qu'on en croise
souvent le mot trahison parce que tous
les paroles et tous les engagements de
renault ne sont jamais tenues à profonde
et bretagne si le site de houdan
effectivement est vendu qu'est-ce qui se
passe alors on a déjà connu ça nous dans
les années 2000 où nous nous avait
revendu un groupe italien teksid et
fêter la déconfiture pendant dix ans ils
sont servis dans les caisses et on et
s'était retrouvé en liquidation
judiciaire en 2009 et renault nous
avaient repris on n'a pas du tout envie
de se retrouver dans la même situation
alors il y a eu les dirigeants du site
qu'ils ont été
empêchés de quitter finalement le site
de caudan c'était mardi ils ont pu
repartir pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
souhaité les bloquer tout simplement
pouvoir discuter avec eux parce que
c'est le seul à les décider seul avec
qui on peut discuter de cherono et nous
faut absolument des réponses à nos
questions parce que comme je vous dis ça
fait un an qu'on est baladé à travers
une produits stratégiques t'atteindre
que les politiques locaux et
territoriaux régionaux ou même au niveau
du ministère de l'économie affirme que
fondu bretagne a un avenir que c'est un
non sens économique et une faute
stratégique de renault mais maintenant
au delà des paroles il faut des actes on
a en a pas d'actes et ça fait un an que
ça dure et c'est très compliqué à vie
pour les salariés nous tout ce qu'on
constate c'est que les volumes
disparaissent au fur et à mesure des
semaines et ça c'est plus vivable parce
qu'ils sont en train d'organiser la mort
à petit feu de maxime qu'est ce qu'on
vous a répondu au niveau de la direction
de renault vous avez pu leur parler
avant qu'ils ne quittent le site ne sont
pas d'image c'est le mépris le plus
complet le plus total donc ça a choqué
des salariés ça les a blessés
la trahison continue c'est complètement
aberrant de la part d'un directeur
deuxième de ne pas vouloir discuter avec
ses salariés c'est du jamais vu
qu'est ce qu'elle représente cette
fonderie dans la région parce qu'elle
représenta représente 350 emplois
directs vont multiplier par 3 autant
d'emplois indirects c'est un fleuron de
l'industrie bretonne ça un fleuron de
l'industrie automobile
donc c'est un savoir faire qui est
générationnel c'est une entreprise qui a
55 ans issus des forges d'hennebont
nous on est tous issus de familles de
fondeurs et c'est comme on dit tout le
monde cette entreprise d'aller à nous et
parce que tous nos familles ont
travaillé et aussi parce que il ya eu de
l'argent investi ici par les pouvoirs
publics donc nos impôts et c'est pour ça
cette entreprise aux irakiens qu'est ce
que les politiques
le coup vous disent ils qu'ils vous
soutiennent dans votre démarche ah oui
complètement on a un soutien unanime de
tous les politiques de tous bords mais
comme je vous dis le soutien c'est une
chose mais les accents veut des actes
c'en est une autre
alors comme acte qu'est ce que vous
attendez de la part de bruno le maire de
on va dire comment on pourrait dire ça à
tendre le bras à monsieur de meo que
renault tienne ses engagements mais 2019
on avait subi un incendie de notre outil
de travail a été reconstruit à neuf on a
une usine qui est ultra performante et
on veut que maintenant renault tienne
ses engagements sur les volumes que
renault nous gardons avant son groupe et
qu'on puisse travailler sereinement et
est normalement est con et tu cette
angoisse tous les jours en anglais alors
vous vous bloquez on le disait toujours
la fonderie jusqu'à quand mais jusqu'à
ce que les actes soient soit concret et
que l'on puisse enfin discuter avec des
personnes responsables parce que nous
sommes des sérails est responsable on
craint pour notre avenir en craquant nos
familles c'est tout c'est juste ça en
fait on veut discuter avec des gens
responsables et pas des menteurs et et
puis que les actes soit concret merci
beaucoup
maël le goff d'avoir répondu à nos
questions dans la matinale de rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes représentant
cgt fonderie de bretagne